I'm so happy to be here tonight to speak
about Debbie Reynolds
Debbi with the gift of always sharing
her spirit and her heart with those
around her Debbie who always brings
laughter and entertainment Debbie who
always feels fully present Debbie can't
be with us tonight in person but her
spirit is here and her family who will
enjoy this honoring of her and we'll
pass along your respect and affection
for this amazing woman the award we're
giving Debbie tonight the Jean Hersholt
Humanitarian Award is presented not for
her body of work as a performer although
we all recognize and cherish Debbie as
the vibrant movie star who brought so
much life and energy to her classic film
roles but for the outstanding work she
has done outside her day job
that to improve our city our country and
the world
Debbie's philanthropy is both wide and
deep she spread her concern for others
across dozens of organizations but she's
also become deeply engaged with
transformational causes and I'd like to
highlight just one of them because in
her work for this organization
the Faye Lian's she's been fearless in
her advocacy not only raising an
astonishing amount of money but also
speaking out publicly about the issue of
mental health mental illness starting as
far back as the 1950s when to do so was
indeed a mark of bravery even braver was
that Debbie could persuade her daughter
Kerry to pretend that she suffered from
mental illness knowing that it would be
good for the
debbie is a founding member of salience
a charitable organization conceived and
sustained by entertainers that promotes
awareness and the treatment of mental
health issues she served as the group's
president almost continuously from 1957
to 2011
thanks to Debbie the fail Ian's have
contributed millions to the mental
health center at cedars-sinai and to
UCLA's operation mend which helps
military veterans recover from physical
and psychological wounds of war
one of those veterans is with us tonight
Joey pulk Joey would you please stand so
that we can honor you
Debbi for everything you are and
everything that you've done thank you